compromis au finish en espagne les douze
enclenche le processus de l'union
monétaire petits pas de membre est
satcher la livre fera partie du serpent
monétaire
les bookmakers britanniques lancent en
france les paris sur la grande boucle la
police met le holà il y à mono paul
d'état
dynamite dans un train à shanghai 24
personnes sont tuées l' agence chine
nouvelle ne précise pas s'il s'agit d'un
attentat ou d'un accident
le ghetto pour les malades cubain du
sida reportage exclusif dans ce journal
sur ce qu'on appelle là-bas un sida
thorium
wimbledon 2e jour et trois gouttes de
pluie navratilova est grave parce
mcenroe à la peine dans un cinquième set
madame monsieur bonsoir pour les
familles et les amis de 58 victimes de
la catastrophe ferroviaire survenue le
27 juin à la gare de lyon il y avait
aujourd'hui bien sûr beaucoup de
recueillement pour une date anniversaire
c'était l'année dernière mais aussi une
volonté de dire que l'on a envie de
savoir tout toutes les causes de
l'accident de ces deux trains de
banlieue qui se télescopent à 19h10 l'an
dernier au troisième sous-sol de la gare
souterraine de paris-lyon à 19h tout à
l'heure a débuté un office religieux
oecuménique sur le quai même du drame
auparavant il y avait une conférence de
presse des parents des victimes pascal
deschamps roger motte
cela alors est placé sur ce même quai il
ya tout juste un an un train fou venait
envoyé un autre ils ont laissé un enfant
un mari un père ou un ami et ils ne
veulent pas qu'on oublie
pour se souvenir une courte cérémonie
oecuménique ou tous catholiques juifs
musulmans protestants ou at&t solidaire
dans la même douleur
un croyant
croyants de différentes confessions de
sa venue nous recueillir
sommes venus dire aussi que ce soir
notre force dans la souffrance et d'être
ensemble et l'association le fait de les
avoir retrouvés aujourd'hui m'a donné la
force de pouvoir redescendre pour la
première fois depuis l'accident sur le
quai sans eux ça n'aurait jamais été
possible
mais au-delà de cette tragique
célébration il ya les questions que les
familles des victimes continuent de
s'opposer aujourd'hui certes la sncf a
reconnu son entière responsabilité
elle a dégagé plus de 4 milliards pour
améliorer la sécurité certes 20 millions
de francs d'indemnisation déjà été
versés mais pour les familles là n'est
pas l'essentiel
moi si je suis là fait clair je suis là
parce que je ne veux pas qu'on mari soit
mort pour rien je ne veux pas que ça
recommence comprenez et je suis persuadé
que si on ne fait pas quelque chose il y
aura encore une mère et des enfants qu
attendons toutes unies au téléphone qui
attendront le lendemain matin qu'on leur
annonce vérité et ça ça ne peut pas être
comparé avec des termes d'indemnités
vous comprenez
les familles regrette aujourd'hui de ne
pas être informées des conclusions de
l'enquêté judiciaire qui seul leur
permettrait de savoir exactement ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là
ça se fera mais ça se fera moins vite
que certains comme la france ou
l'allemagne aurait voulu à madrid les
onze ont réussi à arracher quelques
concessions en margaret thatcher et a
enclenché avec elle puisqu'il y a
compromis le processus d'union
économique et monétaire on verra
d'ailleurs bientôt d'ici à 1992 la livre
britannique dans le sm eux le serpent
monétaire européen compte rendu d'un
résultat au finish avec l'un de nos
envoyés spéciaux philippe sassier
il faut beaucoup de temps et de patience
pour parvenir à servir le jerez avec
cette précision traditionnel à madrid ce
geste dont l'apprentissage est difficile
symbolisait parfaitement la construction
européenne en effet ne s'agit-il pas de
faire sortir les culs des boîtes de
collection pour en faire une monnaie
commune ne s'agit-il pas pour les états
européens d'abandonner un peu de ce
droit souverain de battre monnaie et
d'accepter la création d'une banque
centrale européenne une harmonisation
des politiques économiques nationales
qui interdira par exemple un pays
européen de pratiquer le déficit
budgétaire ou la politique des taux
d'intérêt qu'il voudrait sont tenir
compte de ses voisins en commençant la
journée
ce matin par leur traditionnel petit
déjeuner le président français le
chancelier allemand sap que pour avancer
il faut trouver un compromis qui ménage
les susceptibilités et permettent de
franchir un nouveau pas maggie thatcher
qui refusent toujours l'abandon de la
souveraineté économique et monétaire
britannique était l'opposant numéro un à
ce plan elle n'a jamais caché que
l'europe politique monétaire social
n'était pas sa tasse de thé à madrid l
ami contrainte et forcée un peu d'eau
dans ce t elle a accepté ce compromis
préparé par felipe gonzalez le premier
ministre espagnol compromis présenté ce
matin puis corrigées et adoptée à
l'heure du déjeuner et qu'on peut
résumer en trois points l'union
économique et monétaire
et à la réalisation du grand marché la
première étape de cette union commencera
le 1er juillet 1990 une conférence
intergouvernementale sera convoquée pour
étudier les autres étapes et la révision
du traité de rome
la france qui va demander la tenue de
cette réunion pour le deuxième semestre
de l'an prochain a dû elle aussi faire
des concessions et par exemple accepter
un certain flou dans le communiqué final
comme l'absence de date il lui faut
maintenant au battre le fer tant qu'il
est chaud car si maggie thatcher n'est
pas parvenu à stopper la danse de
l'union monétaire à madrid il n'a pas
perdu l'espoir de la halle en tire c'est
donc pour certains un succès mitigé les
c'est un sommet réussi a dit tout à
l'heure le président mitterrand et
l'europe continue à avancer a conclu
jacques d'heure pour françois mitterrand
donc le sommet de madrid est un sommet
réussi même si ce matin on échangés
entre les deux délégations française et
britannique quelques amabilités pour
françois mitterrand madame thatcher a
constitué un frein à la construction
européenne
pas du tout répondent et on chez les
anglais elle en a été un accélérateur
alors monsieur mitterrand est il fâché
de la poigne de madame thatcher
réponse tout à l'heure au cours de sa
conférence de presse
je suis pas du tout en colère pourquoi
vous avez perçu d'irritation
c'est merveilleux a su mairie et ça papa
les maux du monde et pourquoi se résume
à hériter d'une opposition qui n'a pas
prévalu
l'image peut pas du tout je suis habitué
le produit tout je trouve très
sympathique
noter encore que le premier ministre
britannique estimé de son côté n'avoir
cédé en rien et que les 12 se sont mis
plus facilement d'accord pour un embargo
total sur les ventes d'armes à la chine
l'europe peut-être monétaire elle peut
être aussi histoire de gros sous par
exemple quand les bookmakers
britanniques font imprimer par une
société française des bordereaux but du
jeu parier sur les vainqueurs du
prochain tour de france seulement voilà
la direction nationale des jeux
intervient pour faire saisir les coupons
car il y à un fractionnement monopole
d'état français sur les jeux établi par
la loi de 1936 and gas burget 5 millions
de bordereaux comme celui ci ont été
distribués dans toute la france vous
trouviez ainsi dans vos boîtes aux
lettres ces tickets de jeux imprimé à
evry lyon ou villejuif ici la police a
saisi plus d'un million de ces vignettes
il suffit des deux coché les noms de vos
trois favoris du tour chacun des
coureurs ayant une cote gains potentiels
de ces paris plusieurs milliers de
francs un business soigneusement rodez
entre la grande bretagne et la france un
démarcheur il tentait sa chance auprès
des fédérations de rugby ou de cyclisme
un homme clé travaillant pour le compte
de bookmakers britanniques
j'ai reçu il ya quelques mois un
français me disant qu'il avait habite il
habitait l'ombre qu'ils organisaient des
paris sur les sports en général donc sur
les îles était ce qu'on appelle un
bookmaker il m'avait proposé de faire
des paris sur le tour de france ce que
j'avais refuge et étant donné que
c'était pas un petit peu notre manière
de voir les choses en matière sportive
et puis que ce ne serait pas l'air très
sérieux au départ pas sérieux et surtout
pas légal personne en effet ne peut
utiliser le nom de tour de france sans
l'accord de la société il légal encore
puisqu'en france les loteries de toutes
espèces sont prohibés en france mais pas
en angleterre réplique les parieurs
britanniques
le problème c'est qu'on ne peut pas
accepter les paris
en france mais il s'est tout à fait
légale pour les français dont vous voyez
le pari sur le tour et d'envoyer le mise
avec dans notre bureau à londres on a
à peu près cent mille clients dans le
monde mais surtout en europe qui
pareille toutes les semaines sur tous
les événements sportifs une affaire qui
à l'aube du grand marché augure mal de
l'harmonisation des différents droit
européen pour l'heure seules les petites
entreprises font preuve d'agressivité
mais en 92 il n'y aura plus de
frontières les grosses sociétés
européennes de jeu risque est alors de
s'en donner à coeur joie pour séduire
les parieurs
politique pierre mauroy député maire de
lille et premier secrétaire du ps a été
élu comme prévu président de la
communauté urbaine de lille il succède
au socialiste arthur notebart en
délicatesse avec son parti
création d'un intergroupe de
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
l'instance collégiale rpr udf et udc se
réunira le marty pour monsieur gaudin
cet intergroupe où l'on votera par tête
va dans le sens de ce que souhaitent les
rénovateurs mais ajoute le représentant
de l'udf c'est encore nous qui décidons
le premier ministre était aujourd'hui en
visite à bordeaux sur le thème la
modernisation du service public michel
rocard en visite dans un tribunal de
grande instance particulièrement moderne
est informatisé a reçu pourtant une
lettre des magistrats bordelais qui
demande au gouvernement d'engager
immédiatement une réforme du statut de
la magistrature
considéré je cite comme archaïque à
bordeaux pour antenne 2 jean-michel
mercurol
michel rocard qui visitent un tribunal
en pleine grogne des magistrats après le
non lieu de la faire du cher et le
projet d' amnistie en matière de
financement politique voilà qui était
prometteur d'information mais c'était
sans compter avec la volonté farouche
d'un premier ministre venu avant tout
sur le terrain pour constater les
progrès de modernisation et
d'humanisation des services publics qui
selon lui était la seule nouvelle
intéressant de la journée pour la vie
quotidienne des français donc rien
d'autre à tirer de lui ni sur la loi d
amnistie ni sur les financements des
partis j'ai décidé aujourd'hui le bruit
sonore fait peur notre rencontre ne
concernerait que la modernisation du
secteur public par conséquent je ne vous
répondrai pas plus mais croyez moi je
répondrai fermement dès que l'occasion
sera donnée c'est que michel rocard se
considère beaucoup comme un chef
d'entreprise fort des 6 millions des
salariés de l'état auquel il demande
d'améliorer leur efficacité et leur
accueil bref de se mettre vraiment au
service du public tâche terrifiante
concept il mais qui a progressé à
travers les exemples qui l'a vu
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agisse d'accueil des
justiciables de délivrance des cartes
grises ou de gestion éducative accusé
par le ps de trop faire de gestion et
pas assez d'idéologie michel rocard a
répondu aujourd'hui à sa manière il
préfère changer en profondeur la société
française plutôt que de se laisser aller
aux aléas des réactions politiciennes le
smic demain en conseil des ministres son
augmentation devrait être de 1,9 pour
cent le portant à plus de 5000 francs
par mois ce réajustement et tente de sa
de ce que demandent les syndicats vous
retrouverez vos quotidiens nationaux
demain dans les kiosques que deux
exceptions libération et la tribune de
l'expansion ces deux journaux continuent
d'être frappé par la grève du syndicat
du livre jusqu'ici imprimés grâce aux
rotatives du syndicat du livre installé
à paris ces deux quotidiens pour décider
de changer d'imprimeur le canard
enchaîné qui paraît demain affirme que
le pdg de la société du cher monsieur
dewavrin a reconnu implicitement devant
le juge d'instruction que sa société
avait continué à vendre des obus à
l'iran après 1986 sous le gouvernement
de jacques chirac c'est dans le canard
enchaîné
la chine consacre sa normalisation les
autorités annoncent 15 nouvelles
arrestations de contre-révolutionnaires
et l'assemblée nationale populaire doit
se réunir pour entériner la un jeu qui
frappe les rénovateurs du parti par
ailleurs une explosion dans un train
près de shanghai a fait 24 morts l'
agence chine nouvelle ne donne pas de
version officielle les deux hypothèses
de l'attentât ou de l'accident sont
posées bruno l'adresse
l'explosion a eu lieu alors que le train
s'approchait de shanghai sa destination
finale d'après les informations fournies
par le commentateur chinois la
déflagration due à de la dynamite s'est
produite dans les toilettes d'un wagon
de troisième classe
accident ou attentats pour l'instant
aucune explication n'est officiellement
donné pour étayer la première hypothèse
on doit cependant remarquer que de tels
accidents ont déjà eu lieu dans le passé
les paysans chinois utilisent
régulièrement de l'explosif pour
déboiser ouvrir des tranchées dans leurs
champs ou encore pêcher malgré les
interdictions et les contrôles renforcés
depuis le début du mois il n'est pas
rare qu'ils voyagent avec des bâtons de
dynamite
la télévision chinoise a cependant
largement insisté sur l'explosion elle a
montré l'adjoint au maire de shanghai se
rendant au chevet des blessés et
organisant les secours et aujourd'hui
pour la première fois on évoque en chine
la possibilité d'un attentat après
l'écrasement du mouvement étudiant de
pékin et les récentes condamnations à
mort il ne fait pas de doute qu'ici
certains opposants désespéré connaissent
la tentation terroriste
endroit la minorité souvent une
protection supplémentaire pour les
adolescents ou les enfants aux etats
unis ce principe est aujourd'hui remis
en cause puisque les juges de la cour
suprême la plus haute instance
judiciaire aux etats unis estiment que
la peine capitale est applicable à des
criminels mineurs au moment des faits
antenne de new york pôle nord
kevin standford il avait 16 ans quand il
a commis son crime il attend dans une
prison du kentucky d'être exécuté son
appel a été rejeté hier il keynes 16 ans
lui aussi reconnu coupable dans le
missouri de trois meurtres il est
passible de la chaise électrique john
penry dans un pénitencier du texas
retardé mental notoire il mourra par
injection de poison en 1981 un jury l'a
condamné pour viol et meurtre ainsi en a
décidé la cour suprême des etats-unis
désormais la peine capitale pourra être
appliquée aux jeunes de 16 ans et aux
handicapés mentaux une décision dont se
félicitent les tenants de la loi et
l'ordre mais qui soulèvent de très vives
protestations
je pense que là on a fermé
une voie de réformes très important et
en même temps que nous sommes en train
de diminuer ou de riz d'éliminer en
certains cas certaines des droits
nouveaux ont été créés au cours des
dernières vingt ans on voit ce moment
semble des décisions il ya un diminution
des droits des citoyens privés et une
augmentation
combien de cas des pouvoirs coercitifs
de l'état que ce soit l'état
des divers
dans les prisons américaines 2200
condamnés attendent d'être exécutés
parmi eux 25 ont entre 16 et 17 ans
s'il est vrai que l'opinion publique
demande le rétablissement de la peine de
mort dans les états où elle a été abolie
aucune étude ne prouve que le châtiment
suprême a fait baisser la criminalité
au contraire cette criminalité est en
augmentation constante
elle est la conséquence de deux
phénomènes très précis les armes qui
sont en vente libre et l'utilisation
massive du crack un dérivé très puissant
de la cocaïne
l'amérique attend dans quelques jours
une autre décision très important de la
cour suprême cette fois sur l'avortement
aux états unis l'avortement est légal
depuis maintenant 16 ans mais la cour
suprême un risque fort de changer cette
loi c'est à dire qu'elle pourrait
laisser les différents états qui
composent la nation américaine
libre de penser et de statuer si avorter
est un crime
à cuba l'hérault sont déchu le général
de division ochoa accusé de trafic de
drogue sera jugé pour haute trahison
ochoa avait commandé le corps
expéditionnaire cubain en angola il
était proche du pouvoir mais aussi
accusé depuis des années de
malversations par les états unis il y a
dans ce procès à grand spectacle de la
havane beaucoup de moralisme
révolutionnaire mais aussi beaucoup de
rivalité politique michel mompontet
le général ochoa a décidément pour un
cubain bien des tard il est adoré par
son peuple les fait de l'ombre à raul
castro le numéro deux de l'état il est
partisan de la pérestroïka et fait peur
à fidel le numéro un il est de plus un
trafiquant de drogue et accessoirement
d'ivoire et de diamants il est donc
aujourd'hui accusé de trahison pour ses
trafics variés seulement bien sûr avec
dans le rôle du procureur implacable
raul castro raul castro qui l'accusent
férocement et réclame sa mort raul
castro qui reste le seul dauphin de son
frère aîné c'est la première fois en
trente ans que cuba a reconnu une
accusation américaine dirigée contre son
armée washington dénonce est en effet
depuis longtemps la havane comme une des
plaques tournantes du trafic
international mais si ochoa est le plus
important des personnages aux cubains
accusés il n'est pas le seul dans le box
d'autres officiers vont suivre ils ont
tous deux étonnants point commun leur
immodéré goût du trafic de la drogue et
celui aussi de la pérestroïka de sujets
de cauchemar pour le lider maximo
hasard de l'actualité nous vous
proposons ce soir un reportage exclusif
tourné à cuba par marie dominique robin
et gonzalo harrisson devait y près ce
sujet le sida dans une région les
caraïbes particulièrement touchées par
la maladie
le régime castriste choisi pour les
sidéens le ghetto et l'enfermement cuba
a ouvert le premier sida thorium c'est
la terminer la terminologie locales à 40
km de la havane reportage
ces militaires reviennent d'angola ils
font partie des 300 milles cubain
envoyés en afrique depuis 15 ans à peine
arrivé test anti sida
à cuba personne n'y échappe le dépistage
est systématique chaque séropositifs
détectée est amené dans un sida torrione
ouvert en 86
c'est ici à 40 km de la havane qui sont
isolés tous les séropositifs de lille
actuellement ils sont 300 dont 60 qui
ont développé la maladie ils sont suivis
par 270 agents de la santé les
pensionnaires ville dans les
appartements très confortable pour la
moyenne cubaine ils n'ont droit de
sortir que le dimanche mais accompagné
d'un infirmier ils peuvent recevoir de
la visite deux fois par femelle
au début ce n'est pas évident
l'adaptation n'est pas facile
surtout qu'au début on avait très peur
de la maladie
après on s'y fait
ils font tout pour nous redonner
confiance et grâce à l'assistance
médicale au moins ils nous aident à
prolonger la vie
on se connaît tous car la majorité des
gens sont ici depuis presque présent
j'étais d'accord pour venir ici mais
c'est dur ici c'est dur d'être enfermé
dans ma famille
et à ma ligne j'ai une fille de 7 ans et
je viens vous voir
non elle va à l'école
continuent d'être payés comme avant
oui
lorsque les malades sont en phase
avancée ils sont soignés dans un hôpital
spécialisé de la havane puis ils
reviennent au sida thorium comme cette
fille de 3 ans déjà prêté plusieurs fois
à l'adopter en ce sens bien ici à cause
de notre fille car l'assistance médicale
est excellente
il faut absolument tout pour elle
votre mari sept-îles où il a contracté
le virus
oui en angola
tout est fait pour les occuper mais tant
qu un traitement n'est pas trouvée c'est
la réclusion à vie
moi j'attends de vaccins on verra bien
ce que le destin bretteur
l'enfermement n'est pas la solution il
m'arrive de désir et la mort car ce que
je veux c'est sortir bien si c'est pour
aller au cimetière
l'essentiel c'est de sortir d'ici sortir
de cette prison vous comprenez ya
j'ai perdu le goût de la vie
car il faut briser ma vie
on essaie de rendre la vie des malades
la meilleure possible
at on réussi totalement non sûrement pas
ce système est il parfait non le système
n'est pas encore parfait
si on habitait là fait qu'on aurait
beaucoup de chance de mourir ne serait
ce que d'une diarrhée
si on habitait aux états unis on devra
dépenser une somme folle pour bien se
faire soigner on parle de 148 dollars
annuels on n'est pas milliardaire
ici on nous donne tout c'est une bonne
raison pour avoir de l'espoir
au moment où à montréal le congrès
mondial sur le sida vient de condamner
l'exclusion des sidéens cuve à deschamps
une autre politique celle de l'
isolement car ici on a décidé que la
fonte et de la majorité devait passer
avant la liberté d quelques-uns
la suite de l'actualité à l'étranger
avec aux etats-unis le nécessaire
respect dû au drapeau éric perrin
brûler le drapeau c'est allé trop loin
c'est en ces termes que george bush a
expliqué qu'il allait proposer un
amendement à la constitution américaine
prévoyant l'interdiction de la
profanation du drapeau cette réaction
fait suite à la décision controversée de
la cour suprême qui est autorisé la
semaine dernière la profanation de la
bannière étoilée au nom de la liberté
d'expression selon un sondage 70% des
américains seraient favorables à un tel
amendement
le sous marin soviétique accidentée hier
en mer de norvège transporte selon
greenpeace six armes nucléaires
cette information n'a été ni confirmée
ni infirmée par l'urss le commandant en
chef de la marine soviétique a démenti
par ailleurs qu'il y est eu un incendie
à bord la fumée aperçue serait celle des
moteurs diesel auxiliaires sous marin
est actuellement remorqué vers sa base
ouverture en argentine du procès de
carlos monzon l'ex champion du monde de
boxe est accusé d'avoir étranglé puis
jeté par la fenêtre sa compagne celui
que les argentins surnomme el macho
risque la prison à perpétuité
le procès devrait durer près d'un mois
un adolescent âgé de 13 ans a été
découverte d'une tué d'une balle dans la
tête dans une petite ville de l'isère
près de son domicile
l'armé du crime serait un fusil de
chasse d'importantes forces de
gendarmerie kadri actuellement le
secteur on ne connaît pas pour l'instant
les circonstances exactes de la mort du
jeune garçon 18 personnes interpellées à
marseille elles sont soupçonnées d'avoir
participé à l'attaqué d'un fourgon
blindé de la brink's le 1er février
dernier ce hold up avait rapporté 21
millions de francs
dans quelques jours les vacances et une
saison touristique d'été qui s'annonce
pour les professionnels en tout cas
excellente notamment pour ceux des côtes
méditerranéenne et atlantique
ils ont fait le plein de réservations
comme l'année dernière le pavillon bleu
label de qualité flottera sur quelques
plages françaises elles sont 125 a
présenté les caractères de propreté de
qualité des eaux et d'équipements
nécessaires prototype le lavandou
reportage de claude crespo et aimer
mayol le lavandou ses 4 km 4 temps de
sable fin partagés en huit plages 4600
l'avant du rhin en basse saison entre
100 et 150 mille estivants juillet où
chaque jour débute à 5h par ce ballet de
véhicules
ces gros équipements en y joignant les
camions qui vont transporter les
détritus ce dans les décharges coûte un
million huit cent mille francs par an
l'us 30 mille francs de carburant quant
au personnel saisonnier ou l année la
commune dépenses 340 mille francs pour
leurs salaires
je vous passe les frais d'analysé d'eau
de mer entre autres la surveillance de
la plage par les secouristes
l'hébergement de ces derniers et les
balises un banal l'auteur comme celui ci
vaut entre 500 et 1000 francs et ici en
a près de 120 mais le résultat est là à
quelques mètres du bord des eaux
limpides cependant cette clarté est
aussi dû à une idée de la commune la
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées
chimiquement saison pour être réinjectés
dans les nappes phréatiques
ce sont des expériences qui ont été
mises en place aux frais de la commune
ce qui concerne la balle ou depuis
quatre ans et j'espère que là nous
allons pouvoir démontrer que nous
pouvons après un traitement tertiaire
réutiliser ses deux passions celle
rentrer dans lesquels du lavandou
les loyers des vingt-sept plage privée
ils rapportent plus de 350 mille francs
additionnés et fait la soustraction pour
que le sable qui fuit entre les doigts
de cette noyade soit propre cela coûte
un million de francs par kilomètre
ce qui n'y verrait qu'une principauté
d'opérette aurait tort monaco est un
état de 195 hectares où vivent et
travaillent loin des couvertures de
magazines près de 30000 habitants dont
4500 de nationalité monégasque pas de
forces armées pas de dette extérieure un
produit national brut tenu secret voilà
quelques caractéristiques pour un micro
état qui fête ses 40ans images et points
de vue hervé brusini
la principauté de monaco où le royaume
des images là bas tout commence bien sûr
par un mariage les yeux bleus
d'hollywood se pose pour la vie sur le
prince rainier ce jour de 1956 règne et
grimaldi lui le descendant d'une famille
génoise qui pratiquent en son temps le
métier de corsair devint rainier iii en
1949 un trône des prélats images d'une
monarchie assurément heureuse où
naissent caroline albert et stéphanie
années 60 réalité économique cette fois
il faut moderniser attirer
l'investissement ce territoire à peine
plus grand que l'état du vatican enlève
à la mer 35 hectares terre-plein tunnel
gratte ciel le prince fait bâtisseurs
promoteurs il n'a d'yeux que pour la
mode ernie t elle paraît bien sépia la
photo du vieux monaco image encore d'un
micro pays où tout est simple facile et
luxueux sans impôts ni droits de
succession casino grand hôtel on y
conjugue rolls avec le yacht réalité
immobilière avec société panaméenne
libérienne et proche-orientale prix de
vente du mètre carré minimum 60 mille
francs alors tout change désormais on la
surnomme steph de mosnac et la voilà qui
présente sa collection après son dernier
disque caroline l1 de super vos enfants
quant à albert il donne à la famille des
sueurs froides avec ces compétitions de
bobsleigh
aujourd'hui le souverain fête son
quarantième anniversaire de rennes peut
être at il décidé de tourner la page
mais images ou réalité ce sourire là
jamais on le sait il ne l'oubliera
les grandes cérémonies demain à monaco à
wimbledon avec un retard dû à la pluie
aujourd'hui chez les dames se sont
qualifiés sans difficulté graf et
navratilova chez les messieurs mcenroe à
la peine a finalement gagné gens
m'aimaient
john mcenroe a mis deux sets a retrouvé
son service son tennis aussi seul le
cinquième set a atteint les sommets
pour ce match entre deux volleyeurs de
grand niveau cahill numéro 25 mondiale
mérite mieux à la vue de cette rencontre
des coups assez extraordinaire et des
retournements de situations comme ça
s'étant opéré
cahill l'australien a poussé mcenroe
jusque dans ses plus profonds
retranchements une volée profonde des
points pur si pur que mcenroe n'a pu
s'empêcher de faire sa classique collet
match intense dont il fallut attendre
plus trois heures le dénouement john
mcenroe a souffert 13 doubles fautes un
jeu irrégulier l'ancien vainqueur de
wimbledon devra être plus constant s'il
vous a indiqué à l'ats sion l'humour est
surpris mais
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant vous avez rendez vous avec la
météo mitigée de sophie davant
23h55 aux alentours de 23 heures 55 le
journal le journal d'henri sannier
demain matin les quatre vérités à 7h45
que gérard mourrain reçoit serge july le
directeur de libération à propos de la
grève du syndicat du livre à demain 20h
excellente soirée à tous